president biden faced an intense
criticism over this split screen moment
where he was seen biking on vacation
while images from del rio texas show a
humanitarian crisis with thousands of
migrants packed in squalid conditions
under a bridge the department of
homeland security says it is working to
process and remove many of the more than
12 thousand haitian immigrants camped
out secretary mallorca is forced to go
down to the border today to address the
situation
if you come to the united states
illegally you will be returned
your journey will not succeed and you
will be endangering your life and your
family's lives
this administration
is committed to developing safe orderly
and humane pathways for migration but
this is not the way to do it
okay jesse he said the border is closed
if you see the footage that bill
mallusion caught over the weekend with
thousands of migrants just walking
across the border the border does not
look close and at what point are we
going to get these urgent measures that
majorcas is talking about because it's
now september 20th yeah we're never
going to get it dana biden's not running
the country he's running it into the
ground you cannot have third world tent
cities at our gates he said he was going
to bring this country back to normal
that's not normal you can't have law
enforcement on horseback trying to round
up
waves of west africans and haitians
pouring across the border from tent
cities that is craziness and now we've
had back-to-back months august and
september of shocking images kind of
assaulting the senses of the american
people that we were not told was going
to happen
joe biden was supposed to get a hold on
this stuff and it's exploded under his
watch let's put this in biden's home
turf imagine we did this to delaware
right imagine we ship thousands and
thousands and thousands of migrants into
delaware and they're fishing on the bay
they're riding amtrak packed in unvaxed
little english no skills
where are they going to live in tents
they're going to live at the beach are
you going to put them in housing and to
put them in starter homes you're going
to have to double every classroom size
of every public school district you're
going to have to raise taxes to pay for
the social services they're going to
need health care they're going to need
housing they're going to need welfare
this is what they're doing they're going
to steal jobs they're going to lower
wages and then in a generation they're
going to have political power because
their families are going to be able to
vote so then they're going to just
change the entire direction of delaware
do delawareans want that dana did they
ask for that dana they didn't why is joe
doing that to texas he's not doing it to
delaware he's doing it to texas and
democrats and republicans are saying
slow it down joe hispanics blacks and
whites are saying joe slow it down he's
not doing anything he sits at his little
beach house and he obsessed over masks
to slap on second graders the man is
sick
okay the um sick man there was an
exchange today that i want to get your
take on greg this is our own peter ducey
asking the white house press secretary
where the vice president is
where's the vice president on any of
this isn't she supposed to be addressing
the root causes of migration absolutely
and she has been addressing the root
causes of migration by working with
countries in the region to ensure they
have the assistance they need to reduce
the number of people who are coming and
trying to make those journeys across the
border
greg um this weekend on saturday kamala
harris was at a
college football game doing the
ceremonial coin toss which i don't think
it's a root cause she was rooting
instead of looking for the root cause by
the way i'm opening a hair salon called
root causes in case you're you don't
want to touch up i might need one
is the vacation redundant or is it
preferable right have you ever had a
co-worker who you're delighted when they
take a week off
but there's always the contrary to oh
this is always this has been going on
forever this sort of thing has been
going no this has not this this refugee
camp that's new you got what 13 000
people i can't remember the number in a
city of like 20 000 25 000. that's never
happened would have happened under a
watchful uh administration that takes
the immigration and the uh border
seriously i returned to fox news
reporting the drone footage the
helicopter reporting has forced this
issue not in the cnn style of pushing
innuendo and divisiveness this is not
justice millet or russian collusion or
the find people hoax this is the visuals
of chaos and calamity approaching the
visuals afghanistan except these people
want to get in afghanistan want to go
out but it forces you to ask a question
uh would this have ever been addressed
if it wasn't for the network producing
these visuals and the answer is no
because no other no other media would
have been bothered to do it but we
realized then the conclusion to my long
and painful thought
is that real journalism only exists
if you hate the president
right that's why none of these networks
are bothering to do it they would only
do it about trump but if they if they're
on the on the biden team they're not
going to do this story we would have
done this we were at the border under
trump and under biden and we're
this network is producing pulitzer
prize-winning visuals there and they
will not
get rewarded for it lastly ongoing less
than the education of incentives this is
what happens when you don't have
friction people come in you got to have
friction jessica the mayor of del rio
that's the town where the bridge is um
he said that he was trying to get a hold
of the white house over the weekend and
didn't get a call back now he gets a
visit from the secretary of homeland
security today but that seems a little
like you're not doing your job if you
don't call them back well it's an
emergency level the same level after
you've had a hurricane right where
everyone needs fema on the phone and
they need to speak to the administration
about what they're going to do for it
that's what happens in a city of 25 000
when there are 13 000 new people under a
bridge and when i first saw the footage
i think friday the drone started
operating again i was like this doesn't
look like it normally does at the border
what's going on and then i thought how
did thousands and thousands of haitians
end up there and went and read about it
and these are people who entered central
and south america in 2010 after the
earthquake they worked mostly in brazil
until the rio games when jobs dried up
there and they've been slowly migrating
i'm not saying every single one of them
but it is
it's a new immigration problem that we
have not been talking about certainly
under any administration one of them in
fact um i read this article about
somebody who had a haitian who had
immigrated to chile had been in chile he
had been working and then he heard he
said that he heard that biden is letting
people in so he joins the folks and they
come up and they get across the border
and then all of a sudden he finds
himself on a deportation flight because
they're sending the single young men
back that they can
he goes back to haiti but he hadn't even
been in haiti for 11 years right and on
that deportation flight it was a little
more than over the weekend 300 um
individual men but there were 3 300
migrants who had been moved out from
under the bridge on friday so where did
the other 3 000 or so go somewhere in
the in the middle of the country who
knows where but the
what happened was maybe they were
watching in chile or brazil or other
countries joe biden standing on a stage
with other democratic presidential
candidates two years ago raising his
hand saying illegal immigrants are going
to get government health care and then
they remove all of the the border
protections once he took office they
were the people in this administration
were told by trump officials here's the
road map on how to stop illegal
immigration at the border and clearly
biden and company have been willing to
use their
vast executive power for their own
political benefit when they see fit
they uh thought when they think the
cause is worthy they didn't like the
abortion law in texas that saved more
babies from dying so they unleashed the
whole of government to change things
they didn't like even joe biden was
willing to overstep his executive power
his executive authority knowingly on the
eviction moratorium it was brazen
lawlessness he they admitted it they did
it anyway but this is okay with them
human suffering and misery and burden
financial burdens and health burdens put
on the citizens
of the united states who live in these
border communities it's they're well
it's classified the administration is
certainly not pro-human suffering but
just really quickly on the abortion
point what do you call that bill that
bill is so
out of the mainstream that 70 of
republicans don't even support it i know
it is my point you don't even know that
you are pregnant by six weeks
in a lot of cases i mean
all right well they're true there's
children suffering at the border and
it's been going on all year and what
have you heard out of the body
administration
nothing
dude he's riding his bike around
rehoboth all right well the war was
plenty of time to talk about that texas
law ahead the media turning on president
biden with some saying he is suffering
from a credibility crisis we'll be right
back
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else